with reaction is the author of the
number one New York Times best seller
Clinton cash Peter Schweitzer Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter and also Fox
News legal analyst Gregg Jarrett
all right I want to get into the
Wiesmann thing first then I want to go
back to yesterday's news Sarah if
possible let's start with Weissman well
what we have here Shawn is basically two
different stories now one of the stories
coming from sources is that Andrew
Weissman was contacted by the AP the AP
wanted to meet with him and they went to
have this meeting at the DOJ on April
11th and at this meeting they were
apparently going to share documents and
information with Weissman and the other
attendees at the meeting but just before
coming on the show I spoke with a source
familiar with this issue now remember
the AP is categorically denying this
claim that they were going to share any
information with Weisman whatsoever and
I got a call just before coming on your
show with a source familiar with that
meeting and said there were five AP
reporters attending that meeting that
the reporters did not bring anything in
with them whatsoever no documents they
shared nothing with them and in fact the
source said that there was a telephone
call actually placed by one of the AP
reporters on April 8th to - Andrew
Weissman saying look we're not going to
share any documentation with you we're
not going to give you anything that we
have on point and refusal isn't he
compromised
isn't he prejudiced well this is the
question why would he then lie about
this right if this is if this is the
story coming from from from unwise
mid/side why according to some of the
sources that I've spoken with there was
a problem he had set up this meeting
without the appropriate procedures in
place he didn't call the people that he
needed to come come into this meeting so
there's a lot of concern here if I'm
Paul Matt affords attorneys and this is
all unraveling like this right you file
a motion to dismiss immediately which
forces the judge the hall Wiseman in
front of the judge and say account for
yourself what happened and why didn't he
recuse himself Greg well he shouldn't
he in fact he should have been fired I'm
looking right in front of me at the
Department of Justice regulations DOJ
will not comment about an ongoing
investigation if you do you're fired
if he gives information or collects
information either way from these
reporters he should be fired
unbelievable I got off the phone or
communicated via email with a former DOJ
official he was there for more than ten
years he said absolutely Manta Ford's
lawyer should now file a motion to
dismiss and he and with 4% and DC voting
for Trump they need a change of venue if
we have any fairness in our criminal
justice system I'm sorry Paul manna for
cannot get a fair trial in that area do
you agree yes and and in fact manna
forts lawyers have already filed a suit
all right let me I we got Solent so many
moving parts here Peter Schweitzer let
me get to you so Hillary the fixes in
with Bernie the fixes in with Comey
instruct exoneration before
investigation she pays for the dossier
she tries to use Russian lies to to
influence the general election and then
that same dossier is used to get FISA
warrants against the candidate and a
president-elect it's based on faulty
propaganda lies that she paid for you
cannot make this up in the worst spy
novel or most imaginative spy novel I
could ever think of Sean this has got to
go down as one of the great if not the
greatest dirty trick in American
political history because look at what
they accomplished with us or try to
accomplish with this for this investment
with fusion GPS they wanted to try to
influence the media which they did there
were all these stories coming out about
the FBI's looking around and you know
Trump's Russian ties in this area of
collusion you also basically got the FBI
to take an unsourced document keep this
in mind this is very important fusion
GPS in Glenn Simpsons testimony he says
we do open-source research that's what
we're known for that's what we do there
was no open source information this
dossier at all and that
why Glenn Simpson didn't confirm any of
it because he knew I think that there
was nothing to it it was a dislocation
gender like like yes and Paige had an
agenda like Comey had an agenda and like
so many others had an agenda Sarah let's
go back to the all right
you broke the story with John Solomon on
this program about warrants at at Trump
Tower before anybody else I think it was
in March yeah of last year March yeah
March of last year all right here on
this program now the question now that
we know that the dossier was used I am
getting conflicting reports it was used
in some capacity and it was a large it
was used in a significant way to get the
warrants well I think Shawn this is why
we need to really have this
investigation be made public before the
American people I mean the House
Intelligence Committee is looking into
the dossier the Senate Judiciary
Committee is looking at this we need
those answers I have been told the same
it played partial role in getting those
warrants it played a significant role in
getting those warrants what we need to
know is the significant is the world I
keep morale yes what role did it play
and and if it was not verified and and I
agree with Peter look this dossier they
knowingly lie to a court the FISA Court
did they knowingly give lies to obtain
warrants against a political opponent
because that makes Watergate basically
look like kindergarten
compared to this yeah if they did yes it
would make it look like yeah
kindergarten compared to this but what
we need to know is what are in those FBI
witness files what what is recent house
in title acidity the public deserves to
see it Greg it's a fraud on the court to
obtain a warrant with a fraudulent or
false document and you know it that DOJ
and the FBI knew it was false because
all you have to do is look at the
dossier it's based on double triple
quadruple hearsay no direct evidence
though it's not Papadopoulos Greg the
media's been lying to and it comes from
sources that are well-known within the
Kremlin to lie and provide this
information so DOJ and FBI knew it was
they nevertheless used it as a pretext
to try to destroy Tom trunk to launch
the investigation to spy on him after
they had already cleared Hillary Clinton
even though they knew she had violated
the law more on this breaking news thank
you all